how do I look John haha good Chris good
what to Expect When You're Expecting is
a movie that is clearly not in our
demographic at all we should if this is
the movie that people like us go and see
in droves but my buddy flick pick is
here you guys probably know if you don't
know him he does blu-ray videos they're
great you should really check him out I
mean like he's probably my opinion the
best blu-ray guy and I'm not just saying
that cuz he's sitting right next to me
it's true yes it's kind of like the New
Year's Eve Valentine's Day thing or just
goes from story the story to story and
it's a whole bunch of people who are
either adopting a kid or thinking about
having a kid or they are pregnant and
it's like you know Cameron Diaz
Elizabeth Banks Anna Kendrick Jennifer
Lopez I don't think I'm dissing anyone
um
Randy Quaid or Dennis fish Rio greatness
Clay's a Brooklyn Decker they Rockland
Decker's in the movie who isn't as hot
as she usually is for something it looks
like she wasn't eating too much during
the film I don't know Dennis Quaid's in
the movie though I'm not nadeska layers
in this movie I got goose bumps when he
popped in up I didn't get goose bumps
but it was nice to see Dennis Quaid you
know going into this movie I didn't
expect much and I left with a mediocre
taste my mouth that's not that's all
that sounds like I think it's okay
entertaining movie it said I can admit
that but it's a mediocre time with a few
laughs I feel basically the same way
it's not when you walk into this movie
especially if you're a guy it's just
you're like dreading it you're like I
just wanna hear why am I sitting in this
movie why do I do this and then you just
hope that when you're watching it it's
not you're not going to hate yourself
you're not going to hate life because
you're in this theater if you took your
girlfriend this movie or she drugged you
to the movie or whatever more than
likely you'll find things to enjoy it's
not just it's not the kind of movie
where you just sit there and like ah and
now but there's nothing terribly special
about it there's nothing that funny
about it whenever you have a movie that
has multiple stories there's always
going to be at least one or two stories
that you're like just get to the next
one
exactly get with these characters go
away to get to the one I actually enjoy
watching especially with Anna Kendrick
her whole storyline and being like a
disgruntled young girl who's pregnant
now
but yeah I agree Anna Kendrick was the
one kid that my least favorite probably
storyline in the movie I don't know if
it's come a guy or cuz I've dealt with
girls like this before but she was like
the girl in the movie we're like if I
knew her in real life I'd be like I
don't like girls like that where it's
like the guy is so obviously he's
supporting you in every way you can't
he's giving you everything you could ask
for it she's still crying and
complaining right it's it she laid down
and spread her legs it's her fault too
she's blaming this guy for planting a
seed the whole thing is she like he said
he's always there like for her
throughout the whole thing and then she
just starts treating him like it like
just basically you know she's treating
them like yeah like good you can say it
I don't have a custom my videos big pile
a bitch
oh I'm sorry bitch I'm sorry I see that
sexist would be crazy I all cuss but I'm
not sexist thanks yes I the other
storyline I couldn't stand was Jennifer
Lopez's so that's where I disagree with
her okay she I liked her but that's
probably just because I would love her
to do many things to me and so I have no
problem watching her on screen doing
just about anything so I didn't mind her
so speaking of doing things Cameron Diaz
I think she either worked out took
steroids she was very toned and her face
looked a little stretched out in this
movie which she looked I'm not saying
it's bad she was okay yeah it's just
like I said certain storylines are more
interesting than the others and that's
what happens do you have like these
multiple storyline movies movies where
there's like all different types of
characters but like each one helps the
other this one isn't really like that
this one they're all separate with a lot
of movies like this there's always like
this part that they all kind of conjoin
in a very creative way but here it's
just like oh they're all going to give
birth on the same night I wasn't yeah
we're connected by that was my second
cousin and that that's the connection
but I will say going into this movie now
I see the trailers for this movie when
it first came out and if you notice the
trailers this movie made it look like
all these guys hanging out of a park
talking about their kids that's true it
made it look like that was just going to
be some guys that hang out and have to
go through all these different you know
situations but the movies nothing like
that's just one little tiny aspect of it
that's true I think that was them trying
to get guys in the theater yeah did come
see it obviously that was like my
favorite storyline I think I was the
most comedic fun storyline on that movie
I liked Chris Rock in it I think I was
funny in it I mean I liked his kid in
the movie too yeah the kid he's like a
kid just like beats things every day
except dead animals
yes I feel like they should just maybe
just at least cut out one of those
storylines like to be honest I got to be
honest with you I like Anna Kendrick I
think she's cute I think she's talented
the guy a chance Crawford is his name or
something like that
chase Crawford I don't know I call him
the cheap looking pole Walker
that's very true actually that's a very
traditional pole that is very true I
kind of feel like maybe that story could
have could have been yeah there was no
point of that I mean I won't get into
spoilers but something happens in their
relationship that is significant and I
understand they're trying to address
that that kind of thing happens in a
relationship sometimes but it just feels
like that whole thing was just totally
not on the same level as all the other
stories you said Valentine's Day um and
then this movie compared to that is like
a masterpiece in my opinion I agree this
movie has comedy I think there's
something for everybody and the comedy
is kind of like the bridesmaids kind of
style comedy here and there but not as
dirty not what they don't want poop in a
sink but you're not gonna hate this
movie if you have to sit there if you're
forced to sit there more than likely
it's just there's nothing special about
it it's fluff it's good it's a lot it is
it's really all it is I mean I would
give it I'm gonna give it a see dream to
see I'm gonna give it a see it's it's
it's like an average mediocre movie it's
not my demographic it's not for me and
Riley I think it's a basic
straightforward comedy there's
artistically there's nothing amazing
even though there was a few scenes where
they transitioned through all the where
they give women sonar on their bellies
yeah and what is it I want to see
mammogram but that's reasoning what is
that it's ultrasound ultra can you see
the transition how they I don't know why
that those that were impressed because I
wasn't I don't know I just the movie was
so bland that there was no nice artistic
thing oh the transition the transition
and there's a mom around I quit a
mammogram mammograms or I know what that
is just something ain't in you but I
don't know judge me
I've had one I'll give the movie a C
also you know it's like a one watch
fluffy movie but but I will here's but
here's my special grade for it I'm gonna
give the movie at be on on the chick
flick take her to the movie oh good that
is true because there are certain movies
like if you're if you have a girlfriend
or you're married or something you're
gonna have a date night like if you
drugged if you drove you like
Valentine's Day or New Year's Eve
eyeline or Twilight you're gonna be
sitting there like yeah but
this movie it's like okay this makes my
date happy I'm Adam I'm not going on the
bathroom and slash my wrists with a
piece of sharp glass I'm on the floor
but the one negative thing guys I know
what you guys know this any guys out
there who take women to this it might
give your woman baby fever very true and
that's a commitment you don't want to
that's a scary true so you got to be you
got to be careful of that
and you don't want a kid don't take her
to this movie if you don't want to yes
you good that should be the tagline
history I don't watch it I need my take
it to the movie it comes with a condom
um don't cut that out little okay I said
if you guys haven't checked out the
flick fix videos he you know he does all
types he does movie reviews for
basically he'll go to link in the
description I'll put a link in the
description is what I meant to say but
he does all the big movie uses but he
also does the blu-ray stuff you know
he's really good at it too so if you
haven't subscribed to him do that thanks
Chris until next time guys if you
haven't subscribed to me you can
subscribe to my channel and get
documents stuckman eyes he'll sticky
just stain by the way does he look big
compared to me like we're City is larger
than me bodily bodily then I don't know
man you're taller
okay I'm tall never mind a lot of the
waste yeah I don't know this will be cut
up please don't
I think you in there I like it I like
the proportions anyway for us at the end